I'm trying oh shoot that's the curve my
name is falesha and i'm gonna learn how
to drive stick shift in a manual car I
think that it's gonna be difficult to
drive stick in Manhattan for the first
time driving automatic in Manhattan is
pretty stressful I feel like it's gonna
be okay I learned quickly and can adapt
to high-pressure environment my name is
Chris I'm a professional driving
instructor today I'm gonna be teaching
Felicia and Benjamin how to drive stick
shift in New York City okay so getting
this to move is the hard part
you have three pedals there first one to
the left is a clutch is kind of small
MNN the two pedals which is still the
same an automatic you got your brake and
your gas one of the things you need to
understand is when to use your clutch
starting stopping and shifting let's
disengage this pull up and then try to
push it down it's a little tough yeah
pull it up and then squeeze the button
yeah there you go Shh yeah just keep it
held same time yeah pull up and in
squeeze so we're gonna try to go control
it if you want to go a little bit more
yep yep yep yep yep good be mindful of
traffic anything I'm gonna turn on the
hazards here all right so why is your
foot on the brake oh yeah let go of it
there we are
okay when you feel it vibrating that
means they're almost falling just like
perfect sorry
okay try again better so it goes a break
now yeah you have to look oh okay
steady okay quick - quick want to feel
it roll first work from there you got to
hold it still for a second okay oops
you're put on the brake on that I think
so yeah okay no break no break a break
right now okay yeah steady ready steady
with the left foot look to click yeah
yeah yeah yes
yeah you can hear you're off to the
races now yes okay gotta calm down a
little too close on the right or close
on the right sorry sir all right okay
can you drive that much in the city
overall it's hard to remember sometimes
a little bit more guess there you go
okay there we go we're off I'm getting
it
all right thank you go all right yeah
it's like it's like jazz now you got all
these pieces happening at the same time
the jazz music uh no but I assume it's
like this listen to my instructions cut
you down collection uh nope that's the
ship they're out the left foot oh sorry
okay I'm gonna fix it hold on doing it
just keep your foot there keep that on
the class ship clutches the pedal right
what do you think so far still feel like
I'm not doing it right they need that
they do that beautiful they're all right
I think I did a great job I do want to
take more lessons I still want to be
able to drive a car in another country
be able to drive a sports car feel like
I accomplished a lot Chris the
instructor was very articulate and
descriptive I think I did well thank you
so much okay I'm a pro now
[Music]